y
en un nuevo esfuerzo por frenar el
desabastecimiento de oxígeno y
medicamentos las autoridades sanitarias
brasileñas eliminaron las prácticas
burocráticas para la distribución de
fármacos utilizados en las ucis que
están al borde del colapso mientras el
país no para de registrar más de dos mil
muertes por día
la justicia boliviana amplió de 4 a 6
meses el periodo de detención preventiva
de la ex presidenta interina ya ni me
años la decisión está basada en los
riesgos de obstaculización del proceso y
de fuga y se produce luego de que la ex
mandataria presentará un recurso de
apelación a su detención preventiva
hoy se celebra el día internacional de
los bosques este año la jornada se
centra en resaltar la restauración
forestal tras la pérdida y degradación
de los bosques en los últimos años lo
que genera grandes cantidades de gases
que favorecen el calentamiento global
tenemos análisis en esta misión
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos este
informativo en brásil epicentro global
de la pandemia la máxima autoridad
sanitaria del país eliminó las prácticas
burocráticas para la distribución de
fármacos que son utilizados en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos al
tiempo que autorizó temporalmente
rellenar cilindros industriales con
oxígeno luego de que se reportaran
desabastecimientos en varias zonas del
país el sistema de buses está al borde
del colapso en gran parte de la nación
al tiempo que las muertes siguen
superando las 2.000 diarias en el peor
momento de la pandemia para brasil río
de janeiro cerró sus playas pese a las
críticas del presidente bolsonaro que
aseguró que la medida no sirve veamos
más en el informe de natalia plazas
la mítica playa de copacabana se
encuentra vacía la ciudad de río de
janeiro cerro su bahía que acoge
diariamente a miles de turistas y
locales una medida no también recibida
por todos
y los varios restaurantes los bares y
los restaurantes estaban todos repletos
ayer liberadas con todo el mundo dentro
y la playa el aire fresco el sol y el
deporte es malo no entiendo por qué
cierran las playas no tiene sentido para
mí encontrar a miocardio son la pandemia
en el país vive su peor etapa con más de
90 mil contagios diarios la media de
muertes diarias por semana se ha
duplicado en el último mes con más de
2000 en la última semana río ha visto
morir a 20.000 de sus habitantes de los
cerca de 300.000 fallecidos por la
enfermedad en todo caso son medidas
necesarias pero otras medidas también
tienen que adoptarse no tiene sentido
cerrar las playas y mantener las
iglesias abiertas es uno de los críticos
de la medida fue el presidente ya ir
bolsonaro la vitamina d es una de las
formas de evitar que el virus afecte de
gravedad y uno donde consigue vitamina d
tomando el sol caramba el mandatario uno
de los principales escépticos de la
pandemia ha amenazado con llevar algunas
medidas contra el coronavirus
a la justicia pero sus opositores
aseguran que las restricciones son
necesarias la ocupación en cuidados
intensivos es máxima en 25 de los 27
estados del país es superior al 80 por
ciento mientras que en río alcanza el
95% ante la emergencia las autoridades
sanitarias están facilitando la
importación y comercialización de
oxígeno y otros medicamentos para tratar
a una mayor cantidad de enfermos
vamos a bolivia la situación de la ex
presidenta interina jeanine áñez se
complicó cuando un juez determinó
ampliar de cuatro a seis meses el
periodo de su detención preventiva luego
de que la fiscalía y la procuraduría
argumentaron que hay más riesgos de
obstaculización y fuga
la audiencia se produjo luego de que la
ex funcionaria presentara un recurso de
apelación a su detención por los
presuntos delitos de terrorismo sedición
y conspiración
matías alé descuenta los detalles
de 4 a 6 meses la ex presidenta interina
de bolivia jeanine áñez tendrá que estar
dos meses más en prisión preventiva la
base legal de la decisión es la
ampliación de los riesgos de
obstaculización y de fuga expuesta por
la fiscalía el ministerio público y la
procuraduría un veredicto que no
sorprendió a la defensa de la ex
mandataria preocupados por otro tema la
salud de su clienta debido a que padece
hipertensión los abogados de agnès
obtuvieron una orden para que fuera
trasladada a una clínica pero en la
madrugada del sábado la expresidenta fue
llevada a otro centro carcelario y no a
un centro de salud en todo un abuso una
injusticia y están atentando contra la
vida de mi madre mi madre necesita con
urgencia atención médica el director
general de régimen penitenciario juan
carlos limpias aclaró que la decisión
del juez fue revocada y que el instituto
de investigaciones forenses será el
encargado de verificar el estado de
salud de áñez
con todo lo que tenemos en el centro
penitenciario de miraflores y más allá
además de los instrumentos
de primera necesidad que teníamos en el
centro de de obrajes ahí contamos con
bastantes instrumentos que van a
permitir el cuidado y garantizar sobre
todo el derecho a la salud limpia señaló
que para evitar cualquier tipo de
susceptibilidad y tras una coordinación
entre el gobierno de luis arse y el alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas se
autorizó que una representación de la
onu pueda ingresar a la cárcel para
asegurarse del bienestar de anes la ex
presidenta interina de bolivia es
acusada de participar en un supuesto
golpe de estado contra el ex presidente
evo morales en 2019 bajo los delitos de
sedición terrorismo y conspiración luego
de una denuncia de una ex diputada del
más el movimiento oficialista
este 21 de marzo se celebra el día
internacional de los bosques centrado en
la restauración forestal tras la pérdida
y degradación de los bosques en los
últimos años lo que genera grandes
cantidades de gases que favorecen el
calentamiento global por ello los
esfuerzos se enfocan en restaurar la
gestión sostenible de estos ecosistemas
que ayudan a combatir la crisis
climática y a preservar la biodiversidad
para analizar la importancia de esta
fecha nos acompaña danielle bérgamo
investigador en el instituto de
investigación ambiental de la amazonía
en brasil
bienvenido a france 24 inició
preguntándole los bosques albergan más
del 80% de las especies animales y
vegetales pero cada año el mundo pierde
10 millones de hectáreas de estos
ecosistemas una extensión similar a la
de islandia cuál es la situación de los
bosques puntualmente en américa latina'
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación y bueno traer este tema tan
importante la verdad es que tenemos muy
poco celebrar en el día de hoy pero
mucha área destruida para restaurar la
crisis climática hoy ya no se puede
hablar de cambios climáticos pero sí de
crisis climática que afectan todos los
ciudadanos pues en la amazonía
es la última la última frontera para
salvar de esta situación porque si la
destruimos ya no habrá ciclos naturales
del agua y américa latina tiene un
grande desafío en este sentido
básicamente en los últimos años
principalmente en brasil vemos una un
aumento muy grande en la deforestación y
fuegos también justamente le pregunto
por lo que usted está mencionando porque
la amazonía brasileña pues es el mayor
bosque tropical del planeta y hay un
aumento sí en la deforestación y
consecuentemente en estos incendios
desde que el presidente bolsonaro asumió
la presidencia en 2019 pero ahora joe
biden le pide trabajar en conjunto por
el medio ambiente como pueden cooperar
ambas naciones bajo un liderazgo como el
de bolsonaro
sí bueno lo que se puede decir es que si
hay un cambio de orientación hacia el
medio ambiente en brasil pero la
cuestión principal es que sabemos cómo
frenar la deforestación e hicimos esto
en el pasado y podemos hacerlo otra vez
no no es nada nuevo sólo que tenemos que
tomar medidas urgentes no y es una
oportunidad de colaboración con otros
países como dije tenemos que colaborar
porque es una cuestión global no local
así que cualquier intención de ayuda a
la avenida de donde sea es muy
bienvenida y lo que se puede hacer ahora
es manejar los temas de parar
evidentemente va a diferentes sesiones
pero ese es el objetivo
señor bérgamo muchas gracias por su
análisis y difícil por acompañarnos aquí
en france 24 ahora continuamos con otras
noticias miles de israelíes salieron a
protestar en la noche de este sábado en
jerusalén para expresar su oposición a
benjamín netanyahu el primer ministro
encabeza las encuestas a menos de dos
días de unas elecciones parlamentarias
cruciales para su supervivencia política
veamos el siguiente informe
fuera netanyahu así corean miles de
manifestantes frente a la residencia del
primer ministro israelí a pocos días de
las elecciones legislativas del martes
estamos aquí para protestar contra el
tam yahoo y su gobierno corrupto esta es
nuestra última oportunidad antes de las
elecciones queremos que todo el mundo
salga a votar
tras 12 años en el poder los comicios
del martes podrían poner fin a su
mandato y para el hombre que detenta el
récord de longevidad de al mando del
gobierno
la apuesta es alta pero benjamín
netanyahu está siendo procesado por
corrupción fraude y abuso de confianza
en tres casos su condición de líder no
le protege por el momento pero espera
ganar la mayoría de los escaños para
quizás obtener la inmunidad judicial más
adelante otro tema de descontento entre
la población israelí es su gestión de la
crisis actual la oposición denuncia la
insuficiencia de ayudas para los
trabajadores que han perdido su empleo
por la pandemia
benjamin netanyahu por su parte pretende
ganar votos gracias al éxito de su
campaña de vacunación vamos bien eso es
todo
solo tenemos que vacunar a unos cientos
de miles de personas más sobre todo a
los mayores de 50 años y habremos
terminado con la primera fase será el
final de todo eso si bien el likud el
partido de centroderecha de benjamin
netanyahu parece estar a la cabeza de
las encuestas no es seguro que pueda
formar una mayoría en él
en turquía la policía arrestó en la
madrugada de este domingo al ex diputado
pro kurdo omar faruk argelio blue que el
pasado miércoles perdió su acta de
diputado tras ser condenado por
propaganda terrorista y se negaba a
abandonar el edificio alrededor de 100
agentes realizaron la captura en el
parlamento donde el ex funcionario
permanecía desde hace cuatro días es
médico y político de 55 años y fue
detenido en pijama a pesar de las
protestas de otros diputados de su
partido que lo acompañaban en el lugar
argelio glück fue condenado a dos años y
seis meses de cárcel
continuamos con nuestra serie de
informes sobre refugiados sirios en el
mundo cuando se cumplen 10 años de la
guerra que vive el país hoy vamos a
canadá que desde 2015 ha acogido a unos
25 mil refugiados sirios una promesa
hecha y cumplida por el gobierno de
ellos sin duda muchos de ellos llegaron
al país patrocinados por familias
canadienses esto forma parte del
programa que puso en marcha ese país
para acoger a los refugiados con un
patrocinio que dura cerca de un año y
cubre los gastos de primera necesidad
como vivienda y ropa george y su familia
fueron beneficiados en el marco de este
programa veamos su historia
sólo unas semanas le bastaron a george a
sus 21 años para adaptarse al frío
canadiense y a los corredores
sobrecalentados del metro de montreal
donde pasa hasta dos horas por día que
se fragmenta como el metro como el
autobús la bicicleta también camino y
todos muy bien pero conducir un poco
en su maletín siempre lleva un libro
casi nunca en árabe su lengua materna
antes de aquí sabía un poco de francés
porque en siria había estudiado francés
me parece que leer es divertido como
leer en francés o en inglés o en otro
idioma también el español y toda la
grafía española
nuevos idiomas nuevo mundo lejos de
qamishli donde creció junto con sus
amigos en 2015 llegó a la guerra luego
el exilio con sus padres su hermana y su
hermano vivieron un mes en el líbano
antes de ser patrocinados por una
familia canadiense
al principio fue muy difícil para
nosotros sobre todo tener que irnos de
siria cuando llegamos no sabíamos muy
bien cómo hacían las cosas
como las diligencias para el seguro
médico la tarjeta del seguro para
encontrar un empleo y eso es case
para
seis años más tarde georgia aprendió a
amar canadá y lo demuestra es voluntario
en la cruz roja trabaja en primera línea
contra la pandemia de kobe 19
anota thorne es nuestro turno de
agradecerle a este país que nos acogió
implicándonos de esta manera en varias
tareas he conocido a muchas personas de
diferentes países
creo que si estuviera en síria nunca
habría soñado llegar así de lejos
regresar a siria quizás algún día george
lo ha pensado ya sea para vivir allá o
para sanar sus heridas y finalizamos en
áfrica las urnas abrieron en las
elecciones que celebra la república del
congo en las que según los sondeos el
presidente denis sassu nguesso tiene
amplias posibilidades de ser reelecto
para un cuarto mandato de cinco años
pese a la crisis económica y de ser
acusado de autoritarismo y represión por
varias ong y por la oposición su
principal contrincante es el exministro
de gobierno
white bright fake cole la que está
hospitalizado por kobe 19 podría ser
llevado a francia en las próximas horas
llegamos al final de este informativo
pero los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros volvemos en breve
aquí en france 24
[Música]